with I don't really have an issue with
putting someone that's larger on in
front of a magazine I have more of an
issue with like the Magazine's
intentions because a lot of these big
magazines have promoted like hyper
skinny or underweight women for like the
past 10 years or past decades before and
then just to put a log woman in the foot
of the magazine all of a sudden marn
Monroe she wasn't underweight she was
like a pinnacle of beauty think we kind
of the bodies followed the fashion so
like now you can see like low-waisted
clothing coming into fashion women going
to want to be a bit more Skinner
skinnier or thinner you see Kardashian
taking our implants out to follow that
kind of fashion trend that's going to
come in